the witness is one of the most
challenging games I've ever played
during my playthrough I experience
confusion uncertainty and mental
exhaustion as I tried to understand this
game's intricacies the witness makes few
attempts at hand-holding opting instead
to convey its mechanics and subtle
cryptic ways as you struggle to make
sense of it all but when you do persist
frustration gives way to gratification
this is what makes the witness so
special
unlike many puzzle games it doesn't just
make you feel intelligent it begins on
the assumption that you are intelligent
the witness unfolds on an unnamed Island
within a vast sea this island comprises
a patchwork pattern of Earth's biomes
from a snow-capped Mountain down to a
barren desert scattered throughout these
habitats are square panels each covered
in mazes of varying complexity this here
is the foundation of the witness's
gameplay you guide a glowing line
through each maze and continue from
there most panels unlock subsequent
puzzles but some open doors maneuver
platforms or even activate power sources
what's remarkable is how the witness
communicates it to nuances early panels
are easy as 'king you to guide the line
from point A to B on simple grids after
some time though new symbols and colors
and shapes appear each conveying their
own new rules and there are never overt
instructions as to how these rules work
you learn them on your own through
intuition and logical reasoning it's
also impressive how diverse the puzzles
are and how the witness manages keep
mazes engaging over the course of 25
hours or more it's more impressive when
the witness reveals that its world and
the puzzles therein aren't exactly
separate sometimes they bleed together
what's more the island is open from the
start leaving you free to wander between
its puzzles and locales this is a vital
part to the witness's structure each
area houses a different motif among its
panels based around a certain symbol or
clue in its mazes if the increasing
difficulty of one areas puzzles becomes
too high you can put it down cross the
island and learn a new rule entirely in
many cases the knowledge you acquire
elsewhere helps you better understand
the puzzle you just put down
the witness isn't open-world just for
the sake of exploration if structure
encourages learning at your own pace and
to discuss any of these puzzle solutions
would mean spoiling the revelations that
await you the witness introduces new
ideas with elegance never stating the
rules outright never showing its full
hand but giving you just enough context
and just enough of a push to make the
final leap yourself and after completing
enough of the puzzles bigger overarching
objectives emerge as it does with
various panels the witness communicates
your goals with a whisper offering
nudges in one direction or another as
you make meaningful connections between
disparate parts of the island some of
the puzzles though lack what makes the
rest so good instead of leaning on for
Thought and careful observation several
panels exist to test your dexterity it's
one thing when these examples rest in
optional areas off the beaten path but
it's all the more frustrating when one
of them impedes you from reaching an
important area on the island because of
the solitude of this island in the
various ways its mysteries can unfold
there's not really a linear series of
events but there is a story through
audio logs and other media I won't spoil
here the witness quotes the observations
and experiences of real-life physicists
astronauts psychologists and explorers
each trying to figure out the world
around them and that's what the witness
is about gaining knowledge and using it
intelligently to make sense of the
island and it's gorgeous but exotic
environments the witness moulds its
world puzzles and themes into such a
cohesive whole that if we look hard
enough
we'll keep finding new ways to perceive
it over and over and over again there
are still things in the witness I can't
make sense of some clues I might never
notice and some puzzles I might never
solve but the hints are there it might
not all make sense at first but that's
okay because I'm always learning